the Joe Rogan experience I'm excited for
the fight card next week and in home
because the cards I don't know if you
agree with this the cards up to this
point being dog [ __ ] the main events
have been good but not they've been well
[ __ ] but I think there's almost there's
so many the main events have been great
other than that been awful cards Anaheim
this guy's maybe Ken what else who else
fought this past weekend I looked at the
card I mean I don't know fights in the
undercard there was some good fights in
Jim Miller the soldiers click WETA was
wild jim miller Clay Guida was [ __ ]
wild that was your but in terms of like
title implications yeah this is the big
one this weekend you got your overmare
next week yours Paula Coast yeah Yoel
Romero versus polar Costa which is best
body contest of all time first team all
diamond yeah amazing fight - I mean
Costa is just on a [ __ ] rampage I'm
just going snitch is just like fellas
yeah yeah fellas know the deal yo I was
the Freak of all freaks
you know I mean he is the freak coast is
no punky there was nobody know both of
them both of them were beasts that's an
amazing fight yes deep ADC which to me
is so interesting you know what - it
wasn't interesting to me - I came on her
a while a few months ago and you were
talking about it and I'm like that is a
really good [ __ ] fight because if you
go back and watch the first fight was
steeping dc-dc wasn't dominating and
then clipped them you know and steep a
set time ste pays a [ __ ] like
that's a really good fight man well I
don't like the long way up for steeping
like like when you get those the reason
why I like it is he was coming off of
that [ __ ] crazy war with Francis and
Ghana where he took some big shots
particularly the first round how
impressive is that now that we know what
Francis capable yeah Francis knocks
everybody dead and steep is the only guy
not to just to survive Francis but to
beat him he figured it out like a
champion got him to the ground
you know neutralized all his weapons and
beat him I think I think deceive or I
think Francis for steep a would be
different this time I think I think
Francis made leaps and bound
improvements in confidence it's not so
rock star reckless lifestyle his egos in
check like you sit and talk to my girl
[ __ ] this guy's dead man yeah I mean
it's look and he knows what's at stake
now with Daniel you know in Daniel knows
- I mean Daniels treating it like he's
about to fight the greatest heavyweight
of all time you know that's his approach
I mean that's what he said to me behind
the scenes and but he just thinks he's
better in every way and he thinks he's
going to beat him again and steep a
thinks he just got clipped with that one
punch if he doesn't get clipped with
that one punch he wins that fight you
know what I'll take both arguments yeah
you're right you're right
let's see what happens it's such a great
amazing amazing fight and then you got
Pettis vs. Nate Diaz that's not 170
right yeah yeah look Nate doesn't want
to cut any weight and Pettis just
knocked out Wonder Boy so he's like [ __ ]
it let's do this Pettis last fight was
against the mighty Ferguson right
wonderboy was it yeah
knocked out wunderbar 20 Ferguson was
before that well your person was at 55
that's right and pedis is first fighter
at 70 I mean look man when you when
you've been starving yourself to get to
45 and 55 and then finally fight at 170
and you knock wonderboy out with a
Superman punch class but the only
question was Nate Diaz and I would
assume Nate Diaz I'm sorry Anthony
Pettis to the favor because Nate Diaz
hadn't fought no hot [ __ ] I think he
is the favorite I bet Nate's I bet he
punished the favorite yeah let's check
in terms of you think Diaz would be the
favorite thanks oh dude with the light
kicks from Anthony Pettis well I think
gambling well I think but I think Pettis
the favorite okay maybe you might think
Pettis is the favorite in terms of the
way you view the fight yeah but when you
think about favorites favorites depend
upon who's betting for who I think
there's gonna be a [ __ ] ton of people
betting on Nate Diaz hey Diaz has an
army behind ya I put money he's a huge
star he's one of the least he's like the
worst promoted superstar him and him as
brother Matt thanks for the animation
Giants my favorite - 125 Pettis and
Nate's even money and Pettis is - 130
see what happens it's just a layoff yeah
I agree
it's gonna bet I bet the money you're
probably right the money because Nate
Diaz is so famous the other money's can
go his way what is on the course pull
the rest of the card up so
to the Russia card cuz it it's a great
card even on top of that what else we
got boy Derek Brunson sighs yeah me it's
a little dicey after those top three but
I feel yeah but there's probably more in
the ESPN card let's see what else you
got with the ESPN card yeah oh my boy
slurry hits and a Hagan telling us is a
son Sal that's great for that ran that
he beats him you're a Sutton seat to me
when I talked about guys who were
gatekeepers there I don't believe in the
term gatekeeper were like yo you get to
top 10 the guys in the twilight of his
career to me gatekeepers you beat him
you get title shot yeah a son sells that
guy if you beat him you've got to fight
one or the champ number one or champ and
that's where it's Santa Hagen's right at